TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, we're going
to take a tour of Android
Experiments, next.
I'm here with Rich and Ryan.
How are you guys doing?
RYAN BURKE: Doing well.
How are you doing today?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm doing great.
I'm so excited to check out all
the cool stuff you have here.
You've done some really
cool hacks with Android.
And I'd like to
learn about them.
RYAN BURKE: Totally.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Where
should we start?
RYAN BURKE: We can start with
the autonomous Android Vehicle.
It is an experiment
by Al Bencomo
from San Jose, California.
It has a 5x onboard.
It is using OpenCV passing
the data over Bluetooth
to a IOIO board.
It has four IR
sensors in the front.
As you can see, it's programmed
to follow the color green.
We have this demo ball here.
This guy will go, literally,
to the ends of the earth
to chase anything that
is green, whether it
be a ball, in this
case, or if someone
walks by with a green t-shirt,
this thing is taken off.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
So Isaac, tell us about
this Android experiment.
ISAAC BLANKENSMITH:
So this is a project
called the IOIO
Plotter, which was
developed by a guy named Ytai.
And so in his spare
time, he built a plotter
that basically used an art easel
that was like 18 by 24 inches.
And so he then open
sourced that project
on androidexperiments.com.
And we got really
excited about it.
And so we worked with him
to build this larger scale
version of it.
So the way it works is
that, using the phone,
we take a portrait of you.
And then we run an algorithm
looking at contrast.
And so once we
run the algorithm,
it basically converts it into
a single vector line drawing.
And then we send
that vector line
drawing to this microcontroller
here, which is called a IOIO.
And this board was actually
developed by the same guy who
made the original Pen Plotter.
And so what that
does is it tells
these motors exactly
how much to rotate
to let string in and out.
And depending on how much
string you let in and out,
that repositions the pen on
the paper to draw the portrait.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's a
very big yellow face.
RYAN BURKE: Yes.
Six foot emoji.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So Rich is
going to stand in front of it.
RYAN BURKE: What's
going to happen
is that this app is a
built open framework.
So it has 68 unique
tracking points plus--
RICH HYNDMAN: 68?
RYAN BURKE: 68 plus a
little bit of mobile vision
to give props to our friends
over there on the Google side.
And what it will do is it'll
send those facial tracking
points via JSON over Socket.IO
to a Mac Mini behind this wall.
And then those are then modeled
into an emoji in Paper.js.
So we got a little Android and
we got a little web development
all in the same sort
of thing going on here.
So if you want to step
on this mark, right here.
RICH HYNDMAN: Step
on the marker.
RYAN BURKE: Let me--
RICH HYNDMAN: That
is 6-- look at that.
RYAN BURKE: So there's a
couple Easter eggs in there.
So if you hold--
RICH HYNDMAN: Haha.
RYAN BURKE: Hold a big
smile for four seconds.
RICH HYNDMAN: Haha.
RYAN BURKE: Deal with it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Nice.
RICH HYNDMAN: There we go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's very cool.
All right, Ryan.
Thanks for showing us around.
RYAN BURKE: Absolutely.
Thanks for stopping by.
See ya.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thanks very much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is us.
RYAN BURKE: Look at that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That is really cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm an
Android experiment.
It's a piece of card.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So if there
are developers out there that
have fun doing innovative
and interesting things
with Android, they can
actually get involved
in Android Experiments.
Is that right?
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely, yeah.
They're all submitted through
androidexperiments.com.
You submit your experiment.
The team will check it out.
If they like it,
especially if it
shows something
that's not already
in a current experiment,
then they can integrate it.
And it might end up at
Google I/O next year,
or Mobile World Congress,
or any of the many
shows the team go to every year.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Androidexperiments.com.
[MUSIC PLAYING]